there was a time when our city streets
sounded like this today they sound like
this
but what will the streets of tomorrow
sound like by 2040 it's predicted that
35% of the world's cars will be electric
and from there it's only a matter of
time before the internal combustion
engine sputters out for good how much
will that change our world could the
electric car save our climate will it
improve our health
what does today's data tell us about
tomorrow this is what if and here's what
would happen if all cars went electric
in 2017 carbon dioxide emissions in the
United States were the lowest they've
been since 1992
but at 5.1 billion metric tons there's
plenty of room for improvement with
fossil fuel cars and trucks accounting
for nearly 30 percent of America's
carbon emissions scientists experts and
innovators have shown that electric is
the way to go electric cars are four
times more efficient than gas-powered
vehicles that means that if everyone in
the United States made the switch the
country's carbon dioxide emissions would
immediately drop by eight point four
percent admittedly this wouldn't be an
easy transition since today's electric
cars are on average $20,000 more
expensive than most other cars on the
lot a country full of electric cars
would see the demand for electricity
jump flight by 29% but with more than
half of American electricity being
produced by fossil fuels would the
change even be worth it it seems like it
in recent years the United States has
been turning towards more renewable
energy sources to produce electricity
and it looks like electric cars are
going to become more convenient car
companies like Chevy Nissan and Tesla
are set to reveal long-range electric
models for an affordable $30,000
with everyone driving electric
greenhouse gases would go down while
green energy and green jobs would go up
even today solar panel sales are
doubling nearly every year not to
mention 50,000 Americans die prematurely
every year from illnesses caused by car
emissions millions in health care costs
could be saved by the electric car but
while all this may sound too good to be
true this what if might actually be
closer to when electric car sales appear
to be growing by 60 percent every year
Ford's model-t showed a similar growth
rate around the time the car overtook
the horse so buckle up and hold on tight
because the future is coming up fast in
time we'll see what the road of
discovery has to offer
but why wait recharge yourself soon with
some more what if
[Music]